wie viele von euch wissen leute habe ich
eine etwas mehr besondere beziehung zu
einer anderen youtube randy auf dieser
plattform aktiv ist der name ist die
dürftige mittlerweile schon ein paar mal
gehört haben rebecca boeing jetzt hatte
ich einige videos orakeln gemacht sehr
viele glaube ich aber wahrscheinlich
schon zweistellige zahl damals hat dann
drei oder vier monate pause gemacht
nichts über sie gesagt ich hätte das
ding ist zu hören wir das wieder gemacht
jetzt würde ich wieder drin ist spaß
leute eine zuschauerin hat er angeregt
dass ich mal auf die tik tok von rebecca
bin reagiere was hier diese videos heute
machen weil ich möchte vorne weg
schicken dass ich gar nichts persönlich
gegen wolbeck gering habe das ganze hat
sich nur mit aber jetzt so mihm auf
einem kanal entwickelt dass keine ahnung
es ist einfach so jetzt so wie es ist
jetzt schauen wir mal einen tick dax an
das haben wir 1,4 millionen follower auf
tik tok masala 25,8 millionen likes
marschall rebecca es läuft wirklich
ausgezeichnet bei dem stichwort laufen
leute wenn ihr einen tick tock ansehen
wollt bei dem es nicht läuft gut ich
habe auch nichts gekostet
ich hab den link dazu in die
beschreibung eingeschrieben auch meinen
namen also check das gerne mal ab
vielleicht werde ich in den nächsten
tagen mein erstes tickets kosten also
seid seid mal darf bekkering schreibt in
ihrem motto du was das bedeuten soll
schauen wir uns als kleines wort mal ihr
aktuellstes tik tok an
ok also solche dinger mallorca alles
klar also mehr so sokoll graffin wisse
was man so wird ist für mich heute bei
diesen tecdax immer dieser dieses dieses
über krasse grinsen so rückt jetzt hier
zum 22 das geist im leben so einmal die
das windrad mit seiner abend zu machen
leute frage frage muss man das machen
muss man das eigentlich machen auf text
also ich bestimmt nicht wenn ich jetzt
sage dass ich nicht vorhabe solche tanzt
xbox zu machen so früher war das auf
musik immer so dass man die so gemacht
hatten da geht es ja noch ganz anderen
kontrakt aber das ist jetzt nicht das
ding was ich machen will
aber ja das finde ich bis zur wird also
du strampelt sich so ab sechs dir alles
dann bleibt das du deinem körper drin
hast und musste aber noch geringer ist
das nicht geil das windrad in
astronomischen der geschwindigkeit zu
machen weiter geht's mit dem nächsten
meinen letzten drei gehirnzellen in der
mathearbeit da ist schon wieder das will
dieses grinsen also ich will jetzt an
liquidität rüber kommt der tag da gar
nicht weg aber ich habe bis dato sehr
wichtig abgeschaut muss ich wirklich
sagen also ich kenne die leute auch mal
im alter dematic dort schauen natürlich
das obwohl ich youtube sogar wenn aber
das ist wirklich was ich nicht kann
keiner sagen hat man kann was eigentlich
alles macht man halt so aber ein
bisschen tiefer rhein leite es ist so
sie pochte den muff und auf einmal ist
das gesicht oder so
china moses und ein grinsen digger was
jedes publikum fährt in schande
erbleichen lässt davor leute mit ihren
privaten auch machen wenn sie schlecht
wird euch täglich an mein tag war
scheiße nein nein ihr könnt ihn
rumdrehen einfach mal so durch und das
sage ich von äußerlich völlig das kann
ich gar nicht ist kann ja kann ich nicht
so hart draußen wie sie ihre youtube
videos aber ich wundere mich dass ist
dass ich irgendeine tätigkeit habe dass
hier kein ticket mit dem game master ist
heute was ist denn da was ist da
schiefgelaufen hat der game master in
eigenen account oder wie auch hier jetzt
glaube ich wirklich wissen tiefer aber
jetzt kommt damit
es ist wirklich so geistig hängen
geblieben normalerweise würde ich jetzt
sagen was für eine komplett hängen
geblieben ist ihr wisst was ich meine
leute aber ich glaube das ist einfach
tik tok für uns oder und das
mindestalter steckt ob diese so hängen
überleben weiter es war komplett
unabhängig davon als ich meine es ist ja
nicht mal in dem fall ist es ja nicht
mehr weg hat die jetzt außerordentlich
eng geblieben ist ist es einfach es ist
einfach dieser alien nein nein
leute welt
[Musik]
das ist so weit weg wieso ist in jedem
von diesem trick dogs immer so
wieso ist es da drin warum wird eine
schusswaffe geladen so was hat eine
schusswaffe laden mit diesen dingen zu
tun das ist generell der sache dich
nicht verstehen langsam dass das gerät
weit verbreitet ist warum ist das ist
das geräusch von einer durch ladenden
schusswaffe wieder bereit ist einen
menschen zu töten
warum ist das entwickler kannst du in
der 38 jährigen sehr beliebtes oder so
da habe ich auch daran gefunden dass das
ist wirklich das dass das grinsen der
bright kickende lebens boost wenn du in
gewissen tanzt ganz aggressiv und hat
aber ganz anders in dem moment wo sich
hoch kommt auf einmal hat sie mit
depression überwunden oder wie das ist
tatsächlich das tatsächlich fanden
das tatsächlich fanny geht nicht dass
das lustig wenn du erster hat der
quartiere die klasse so betrittst weil
du als hat die ganz nah sind ganz zu
machen doch ultimatives gelernt dass das
könnte natürlich meine kleine schwester
seien leute ich sag's euch wie es ist es
könnte meine kleine schwester seite bin
ich stolz darauf ist sie stolz auf nein
aber der dass es funky wollte er jetzt
damit habe ich den zuschauer wunsch
erfüllt jetzt habe ich auf ribbeck
allerdings tickt ums reagiert ich hoffe
es hat etwas mit eurem tag getan es
bereichert oder irgendwas damit gemacht
oder ihr wissen einfach was ich
vorgeschlagen die abonnenten mein kleid
bin der star aus macht's gut